depuis c'est toi et seulement toi mon
coeur vert quand j'entends avoir tu es
mon oxygène et mont soleil quand je
tapais reçoit respire je m'éveille
c'était un petit extrait de ses toits la
première chanson écrite par mellon la
jeune artiste yvelinoise sort bientôt
son premier rhdp le 13 octobre donc mon
épée qui sort donc dans deux semaines et
donc cinq titres le ps appelle nouveaux
défis et
figure un clip au 6e relais 18 parmi les
titres représentatifs du projet le futur
clip de thalie et la chanson éponyme
nouveau défi dans cette chanson masse je
pense que c'est un peu à l'image de ce
que je veux transmettre de manière
générale c'est comment j'ai commencé la
musique surtout pour un premier refus je
pense que c'est intéressant de parler de
ça où j'ai commencé la musique qu'est ce
que ça me procure en fait c'est vraiment
des moments plutôt intime où je me
retrouvais moi même dans ma chambre avec
ma guitare sur mon lit y est voilà c'est
comme ça que ça a commencé c'est le
nouveau défi un ep fruit d'une passion
de longue date pour la chanteuse qui
s'exerce sur son temps laissé libre dans
les études ça fait donc depuis
deux ans en fait que je me suis mis à
vraiment à fond dans la musique mais
sinon j'ai commencé vers l'âge de 11 ans
où j'ai commencé à jouer de la guitare
pour m'accompagner au chant sur des
petites chansons voilà j'ai commencé
dans ma chambre à 36 mois une passion
que mellon ne vit pas que dans son
studio puisqu'elle monte aussi sur scène
elle a chanté notamment aux dernières
fêtes de la musique de verneuil gars lui
ou encore houdan